Coffee on a Tuesday and block 36,
so living in New York City for a few
months now.
I've noticed that a lot of the shops and
restaurants are cash now.
This is generally pretty annoying since,
as I imagine a lot of you out there like
me and I've gotten pretty used to paying
for things with credit or debit card.
So the question is why?
Why do so many establishments only
accept cash?
What's the incentive for them to be cash
only in June,
let's say you're buying a $2 cup of
coffee.
Okay,
so you hand over your credit card to the
Barista who swipes it in her credit
card.
Trump,
you know you've seen,
you've seen what those things look like.
That thing reads the magnetic strip on
the back of the card and sends the
transaction to the acquiring bank.
Acquiring Bank pays the coffee shop $2
and the acquiring bank,
it's their $2 from an issuing bank.
Think Citibank,
Wells Fargo,
Bank of America,
which in turn takes the money from your
account.
This relationship between the coffee
shop and the acquiring bank is called a
merchant account.
When the coffee shop opened up,
in order to get one of those fancy
credit card terminals,
it had to set up a merchant account with
an acquiring bank.
Then it could take your plastic.
Are you with me so far about merchant
accounts work and a lot of different
ways,
but all of them are going to impose a
certain number of fees on our little
coffee shop.
Some of those feeds come from the
acquiring bank,
but most are coming up through the
system from the issuing bank set by the
credit card companies,
mastercard,
visa,
discover,
so when our coffee shops swipes your
card and for every other card and
swipes,
the issuing bank is going to charge a
small interchange fee.
Most commonly these fees are set up into
what's called a three tier pricing
system.
Now,
a normal swipe of the card,
that's going to be first tier and you'll
take the smallest charge of all,
probably about one point two percent of
the cost.
The fees don't end.
Their car doesn't get accepted the first
time.
That's a nuisance.
Every swipe,
no matter what,
if it's going to the issuing bank,
that's an authorization thing.
At the end of every month you have a
statement that didn't pay enough and
these that.
Don't worry,
we'll just add a little bit more to make
sure you hit your monthly minimum things
settling out all your days.
Purchases.
Well,
that's a batch we need to use customer
service to figure out what the hell is
going on with all these fees.
Customer service fee.
Okay,
so you've had enough.
You're sick and tired of the fees you
want out of this credit card thing for
early termination fee.
Sorry to be sure there are good reasons
for charging our little coffee shop
rates and fees.
There is such a thing as transaction
costs,
but as you can probably guess,
there are serious abuses as what an
enormous antitrust lawsuit which was
filed by 7 million merchants in 2005 was
settled earlier this year in which the
car companies paid out seven point
$3,000,000,000
with a beat.
The accusation was that credit card
companies had colluded with banks to
engage in anti competitive activities
which allowed them to raise fees higher
than normal on credit card purchases
without letting the little coffee shops
of the world raise their prices to
accommodate.
In addition to the payout,
the lawsuit changed just that it allows
merchants to raise their prices to
accommodate credit card fees.
The thinking was that if they could do
this,
make a dissuade people from using credit
cards and the credit card companies will
be forced to bring the transaction fees
day,
but with a whopping 68 percent of all
credit card purchases coming from visa
and mastercard,
that may be a pipe dream.
Maybe you can understand why a lot of
small businesses don't accept credit
cards.
They can't afford it and they have to
hope that people like me will go out and
get the cash instead of going somewhere
else like starbucks who can handle the
feets and I would do it too.
I get real money.
The problem is that the ATM next door to
the coffee shop,
it charges me 2:50
to take out cash.
Fifty two books,
52 weeks.
Fifty two books.
Did you weeks?
If you follow me on Tumbler,
I will feel bad about not reading the
books if I don't read them.
So that's why you should follow me
because you are the ones that are gonna.
Help me finish all these books.
Support small business.